bonsoir
comment savoir wahou 2020 quelle année
éclaté au sol on est d'accord
ah la la si 2009 a été une série ce
serait la dernière saison de game of
thrones nul pourtant départ nos étaient
motivés on a commencé 2020 2020 c'est
mon année personne pourra me stopper
puis on s'est fait bouffer vraiment
c'était bouclé en assignant pls en 2020
chaque jour y avait une dinguerie chaque
jour les grèves la pandémie l'assassinât
de georges floyd afida turner peut être
présidente est ce qu'on n'a pas assez
souffert sincèrement la mort de kobe
bryant la mort de black panther jean
marie bigard qui veut se présenter
est-ce que 2020 est allé de merde la
question elle hésite répondu il faut le
savoir
donc si 2009 a été une chanson pour moi
ce sera un featuring entre jean marc ou
à loudes et francky vincent arrêter ça
[Applaudissements]